in this capture we will see the cure
learning regression
logistics
so we saw that we could derive the
the tax collector's box we violate the
principle of minimizing a loss
we also saw that if we
did that we had to do some
approximations ie if we
wanted to see the mouth of the tax collector have
as an algorithm that minimize a
some loss
unfortunately we can not see it
exactly like a licensed person who does
gradient descent because at the point
hxx is equal to zero
we have a problem or the loss is actually
no rivals ie we did not
not to drift to the one we can
calculate by our elements in the
rector w & cie wxx equals zero is
one of the consequences of this is that
learning can be a little
unstable and so when we see her here
it's an algorithm that poses a problem
and who has the advantage between
other than as
learning will unfold
optimizing the average loss on
the training set will vary from
way more list of way less unstable
and so that will give us an algorithm
which is sometimes easier to analyze
at the level of its convergence then the
progression of learning
so that's the war we're going to see that has
this property is the regression
logistics versus the tax collector have
in fact there is not much to
change what we are going to change is that
rather than make a prediction
direct from the class either 0 or 1
when we are going to compute hdx actually our
model he will rather predict
yes predict a probability that our
input x belong to the class on
could have been moderate the probability
that entrance to leave with their 0 that
change nothing but the signares witness of
obviously if
model the probity of belonging to the
class does so h2x for regression
logistics it does not correspond to either 0.1
but it will rather match the
model belief that the input x
belong to the class and we are going
mobilize this first in the form
of a probability actually it's fine
give a probability according to model that
x belong to the class so that there
be galley and to do that we go
use a predictions function
so a model that is going to be very
similar to the perceptor
we will once again make the product
that with the rent with you the parameter of the
bright blue xx but rather than passing
this result 7
this calculation is through a cei function
we will go through a function
called the logistics function or
logistics in English which is also
sometimes called the function if Moses
which is illustrated here so it's a
function that looks a bit like the
function is the function if we
remember gather here and so that
it's zero in this long time that wxx
is smaller 0 and then suddenly 0
it goes up to 1 to double times exqi more
big so they have for the function
logistics in fact we will rather have
a function lice
it's a bit like an approximation
finally list of the threshold function the
very hot function and this
function there and the drifts abl everywhere
we do not have the continuity problem at
zero point and what will make us go
to be able to apply the December war
two guards without problem at the level of
some of the payroll calculation and the
logistic function so its form by
my tricks and the following form so the
logistic function applied to wxx and
1/1 + the exponential minus
wx is ok so general way the
logistics function or function
sigmoid it's the same thing on a
entrance to it's just one on one more
the exponential of less
entry
and so that's fine it gives us a
optimization problem that is going to be more
smooth we have no problem derby
which is not defined now commented
what we do with the ex classification
model there to just choose the
class that is most likely according to
our model so if h2x and bigger
treat at 0.5
we will choose class 1 it is the
class that is most likely according to
our model then if not you choose the
class here what the world is a
more visual commentary illustration
our algorithm some navigation
logistics calculation
h2x when you need the product
than at their den x and w so that's the
sum of 6 xw 1 x 2 x w21 located
until ex'im time wm we do the sum
of all that and we go through the name
arctic line and showcasing
ideal Ticino or logistics and that that
gives us our exit from another
model this illustration the and takes the
form the practices just to see the
kind of calculation that we are going to be
practice later also when we go
talk about neural networks
artificial
ok so we define it
h2x now to make
learning permissible to losses
we have to define a loss so our
lass function is in regression
logistics lodges the loss or we go
use it's going to be what's called the
Entropy lacrosse that takes shape
next
it will be less yt times the log buy
xt - 1 - yt times the log of a month hdx
Say it's a form that looks like a
little strange maybe but for good
understand what it's like to watch
the two cases that can happen so
the two possible values ​​of not moving away
which is price is equal to 1 6 and that's
from class 1 or 0.6 was
belongs to the class zero so 6 yt
is equal to 1
we will see that his disappearance
yt is equal to a nice to have a minus
1 2 0
so that everything ends there
ferret here so let's say that the loss
in fact your correspondent - loeb 2 h
two excited
so we will try to minimize - the
pledge of equity is the same as
maximize log of h2x earth and since
loeb it's a function that is
now monotonous growth with the
same thing in fact that maximize h2x
until hd exist this is the part that
xts is equal to 1 knowing x had
minimized this flat pair in the https
galls has a it's going to be the same thing as
maximize the probability that the model
model a thing or make yt equal
to 1 for the x in question so of in
to contract gala we will indeed have
a workout that will maximize the
probability that the model has thing at
does yt be equal to 1 so exist at
from class 1 for our example
and it and maintenance did the same
thing i'm going to kidnap the kid are doing
the same thing for y is zero
well it's m6 who will disappear is m6
va is equal to 1 before 1 - 0 and so this
what will happen is that we are going to
minimize - loeb 2 1 - completed xtc la
same thing as just maximizing the log a
excited month so minitel negative - a
function it's the same thing as
maximize a function and then again
once maximize the look of a - hd
excited it's going to be the same thing as
maximize one month hdx so you're the same
thing for the body y tega 0 it's
as on maximize 1 - h to exist for
equity data and hdx tc policy
direct is equal to 1 knowing etc according to the
model so 1 - this is the policy to
y is zero to exist given
according to the model so in the case there is
equal to zero for the examples that are
labeled according to class zero we're going
rather maximize the probability according to
our model that yt be is equal to zero
knowing then avoid maximizing his
trust in belief that
leave belong to the class irritated
gaza so that's for the function
loss to explain why it's
a loss function that makes sense and
remain ultimately only to derivatives the
learning rule for descent
of guards who simply take
each of the parameters of the country then of there
subtract a learning rate or a
gradient tax that's called
sometimes times the partial derbi of my
loss with respect to my parameters and one
strikes at the diversion here but if we
does the partial derivatives of by
report a parameter w here it lies
that we get this form here and we
notice that it's exactly like a
times the same shape as for the
collector
but what has changed is necessary
remember that hdx for the
logistic regression this is not the
threshold function on applied to wx
external is not it for regression
logistics but it's rather the function
logistics or symrise applied to ew times
exit so the rule learns exactly the
same form but that's the definition of
hd explains that they come charging so
that's the learning rule
for logistical appreciation and for
lead a regression model
logistics
what we do is the descent of
stochastic gaza that is to say
interests especially the examples
drive then to each example we
would calculate this update where there we
will do that until we reach
some certain stop criteria by
example to rsa criteria would be that
the error does not change more than
certain threshold where we could determine
a number of iterations taken so that's it
so we can see that we managed to
hervé still quite easily
simply defined according to loss
and a h2x prediction model does
then people just did
applied the derivation procedure for
get our
learning rule and like that we have
got a new algorithm
of learning which is the negation
logistics